how hard did you work on this mustache
yeah we've been together for about a
month and a half
uh and my little angel here and and uh i
wouldn't touch it too hard it might
break off
it's it's awful it's funny it's hard
enough going out in public like
let alone now on national tv with this
right my mother said she's like you're
not really going outside like that
right right what is it about the state
you think it looks it has a little bit
of an early look
the problem is i have the the i have
very few follicles i'm very
like yes so we all we all the three of
us it's like this is like
some kind of like a support yeah exactly
but uh
but but the follicles that that do grow
the hair is like it's a long hair it's
like the hair will grow and it's like
thick and powerful right but uh there
just aren't enough of them to cover
powerful yeah that's nice my publisher
showed me this thing uh she found on the
internet some website like thugs
these girls like kind of make fun of
celebrities and i was it's flattering to
be considered
i guess just you showed up on fudge bugs
yeah and they described they described
it it's actually really funny they
describe it as reedy and pubic like
facial hair
which is very accurate yeah you know
what's interesting here though
there's there's a space a definite mason
dick
i'm just getting close i'm not actually
touching it there's a space in the
middle there's no connection
right right there's there's not a single
follicle to be seen
right down the middle there's nothing
when you say cubic like i wanted to back
away
but moved in did you notice that that
was the magic word for casting did you
notice that anyone noticed that
i retreat acosta's all over it
um uh
i i'll try and move on yeah that would
be good speaking of pubic
now listen uh
thanks pal good to have you along nice
to have you
wow people like a nice transition now
matt dillon is in this movie herbie
fully loaded and i understand that when
you're on the set you came up with a
matt dillon impression
and you is this true uh i i i grew up
with matt dolan
like you're such a big fan of his and
and uh just watching him not you
actually grew up with him right no no no
not literally he was in the house and he
was kind of like uh
but yeah i i kind of started doing uh
hey man
hey what's up justin he kind of like
kind of rubbed off on me a little bit
that is him i've i've had him he's been
here yeah yeah he's intimidating you
know he's got a big jaw and
he does this but he's a great actor so i
was doing the impression for for people
in the crew and like
behind his back it was really lame and
and one day i was talking to him and he
was like
are you ready for work man we're going
to go do some work with a magic car
today yeah
and uh we're going to go work with you
today yeah no it's a great conversation
uh
and one of the makeup ladies came up and
they were like oh justin why don't you
do the impression
uh that you've been doing with matt for
matt and all of a sudden every idiot
does that i don't know
i know i think the impression you've
been doing behind his back four yeah
he's been
saying you're a jackass right and and
matt was all of a sudden like
oh yeah oh you do an impression of me
you know my god
i was like his hands in here all the
time i completely buy it he does it
right
he's keeping him warm yeah hey man uh
any and he's very
the grabber he's right right right but
so he was like oh yeah
yeah let me see it man i love to see it
but like kind of challenging kind of
like aggressive
i can totally this is him yeah like
bring it on yeah yeah yeah yeah
he didn't say that but he uh so i did
like a half-hearted and prayed i was
like you know
kind of like this and he was like it
doesn't sound a thing like me man
and then he said then he started calling
people over like minnie's mad hey alison
come over here does this sound anything
like me
dude again do it for her right
i am also told we've all seen the movie
silence of the lambs i know this is
crazy
but someone's telling me backstage that
you do an impression of the serial
killer from silence of the lamb yeah you
do that impression
ted levine he's actually a great actor
uh you know
he um put the lewis from the basket
conan i want to know was she was she a
great big fan person
these are great these are good
impressions you don't see every day
these are eclectic i like i like ted
levine i like the idea that afterwards
television such a good actor but he was
so good in that role that he had a hard
time getting work because his voice
sure right but i saw him in this movie
once i think it was georgia with
jennifer jason
he plays like a stay-at-home dad like
this really innocuous but it's really
creepy because he's got these lines like
uh
you want me to pick the kids up from
soccer practice
it's over yeah it's hard eddie what do
you do with that yeah that's a hard way
to go
man uh now uh herbie fully loaded
is uh is in theaters now and uh your
career is going great you're doing
really well
hey thanks so much for the high point
i'm a big fan of the show wow well
thanks so much we'll come back soon
you're a really funny guy thank you
captain robbie knievel